cicciolina quelles sont les personnalités
célébrités avec qui vous aimeriez faire
Je garderai l'amour cicciolino mitterand moi
très semblable et un turin socialiste
sliac pas de conceptions pas chirac pas ça
Je le ferais mais je n'ai pas encore connu Reagan
aucun collègue je ne ferais pas l'amour
gorbatchev gorbatchev est un drôle de gars qui sait
peut-être comment pas avec khomeiny pas de méchant
khomeiny qui avait fi Kadhafi est un
Colonel je suis contre les colonels
noyer non déjà dirigeants qui oui je le ferais
pourquoi pourquoi une personne extrêmement
doux et sûrement à qui sait je ne sais pas
Je dois y réflechir
Hitler non
mao tse tung mao tse tung et je ne sais pas
encore
peut-être oui seul ou non reine elisabeth la
deuxième et je ne sais pas moi qui sait si la main
aimer alors s'il aime la nature
amour oui elle dit non pourquoi
car il est déjà occupé avec des partenaires ciolino
mari stefania di monaco
stefania est très moderne et très libre
donc c'est peut être
caroline de monaco caroline
non la famille purus est contre elle
défaillants vous avez un merveilleux cicerino doux
doux où même cicerino berlusconi
berlusconi est très doux je le veux
tres bien j'adore
et tu es magnifique tu es né dans
Hongrie pour ridiculiser la démocratie
quelle preuve avons-nous que vous n'êtes pas un
taupe kgb
mais qui sait si je ne le suis pas en fait
est venu en Italie pour le déstabiliser
État italien qui sait ce que je ressens
nous avons que vous n'êtes pas un transsexuel
Je vais vous montrer quelle preuve nous avons
que tu n'es pas là pour allumer des lumières
à tous les italiens
ben je dis on voit que la glace ne fait pas
existe
faisons-le tous ensemble avec
nos produits en toute liberté
joyeusement cicciolina tu aimes jésus
pourquoi un homme nu sur la croix qui
nous avons la preuve que tu n'es pas satan je le suis
catholique qui a écrit le lâche
qui a écrit la bible n'est pas toi
tu sais non non merci ce n'était pas beaucoup
n'ont plus été mais aucun
Il sait
oui aux tubes astori sa main de paul
rimini rizzo au temps du riz amer
était de
quel est son nom et avec mangano no silvana
mangano
Je ne l'ai pas vu mais je peux dire que j'ai
vu que j'ai vu à la télévision et
première fois c'est la comtesse pieds nus
qui était l'amant de léonard de vinci
qui a causé par le joyeux
oui oui oui eau eau a quel age wagner
est devenu le sourd non et wagner
beethoven et bétonnières beton et jusqu'à
quel âge la femelle et les serpents
elles allaitent leurs bébés qui ne jouent pas
ce n'était pas qu'ils faisaient de toi une femme
Oui, vous obtenez une demande pour nous
Nazis nous avons coupé en petits morceaux ou
tous ensemble depuis quand les nazis
ils ont envahi l'angleterre sur commande
par rudolf hess moneypenny qui était dans
1942 tu sais vraiment où c'est
république démocratique de sildavie mais je
il semble qu'il soit maintenant devenu Romains
qui a écrit la bible
personne ne sait que tu as vu son amertume
par paolo rimini ceo très récemment
J'ai envoyé sur la belle télévision
et à peine dit qu'elle était l'amante de
léonard de vinci qui a pensé pour
joyeux
Je pense que oui à quel âge de se baigner
est devenu sourd mais n'était pas vraiment
venir le sapin au moins jusqu'à laquelle
les serpents nourrissent leur alimentation
petit et privé à abc sa well vi
nous mettons